so you know doing for example funding it
was a crazy thing three years ago nobody
knew about it but suddenly it exploded
and one big and there you know there
were we with our great project that were
you know already done or for example i
think is gonna happen more or less the
same with day and bates like three years
ago were three crazy not guys now people
is you know you've been hollywood
starting to you know moving towards that
direction so i think we are we've been
very lucky I guess lungs will have had a
really hard time because he was much
more advanced on his time but you know
that happened to us to its difficulty to
be a pioneer they need to do it anyway
it's like you need to open open the fat
so is that something that you've
experienced and how do you handle that
if people seem to push the ideas aside
you kind of just use that model keep
calm and carry on or you just I think
there are three three things we did it's
like work work and then work it's like
we just kept working even though the you
know everybody thought we were crazy in
many ways and we were so sure what we
were doing that you know the only answer
was to keep working on that keep telling
people get and in the end you know even
though we were saved like a thousand
knows maybe for each one of them we had
a guess at some point and and that's why
we were able to make the film and I'm
right all the money and now we have
which is very cool absolute freedom to
do whatever we like with the
distribution just like we have a film we
own the rights we don't have and we
don't owe any money so it's like we can
do whatever we like and we can
experiment we can try crazy things and
see if they are so crazy or not
you